Norbert brassil belge et fidèle grennard
il parcour en tenue les rues de waterlo
dépositaire et défenseur ardent de la
pensée
napoléonienne la grande question que se
posent beaucoup de Français qu'aurait
pensé Napoléon de la politique actuelle
en France ah Monsieur écoutez si
Napoléon serait là il y est toujours
mais s'il serait là en cher et en os je
suis certain qu'il chercherait un
bazooka c'est bien bazooka qu'on dit et
il descendrait tous les Français qui le
dirigent en ce moment parce que la
France Monsieur on la divise pas vous
croyez que le général de Gaul diviserait
la France comme on la divise en ce
moment mais c'est pas possible ça être
français n'est pas une nationalité c'est
une dignité et vous n'en avez plus nom
de Dieu les chefs syndicalistes c'est
pas beau mais les multinationales ne
sont pas belles non plus et puis il
s'agit pas d'être à table et de boire le
bon vin il faut réfléchir avant d'avoir
bu